everybody I'm trying to enjoy this and
not getting a heart attack at the same
time so when I was younger I used to
think that making films was some kind of
a utopian dream of mine because films
were probably made by some people you
know somewhere in the United States or
whatever I couldn't have imagined to
have the chance to make such an
incredible journey with my own film one
day this wasn't only possible because I
started to believe in the importance of
making films but also because a lot of
people believed in me many people have
put all their energy in this film first
I would like to introduce part of my
crew it was huge tonight so this filippo
gonna be the producer of Odeon I should
all get the actress unfortunately the
second actor Michael Manchanda can't be
here tonight with us and I want to thank
both of you for your unbelievable work
and your trust in me
not only I am happy that we made this
film together but I'm also grateful that
the two of you became my friends special
thanks to our whole crew and cast to
everybody who helped us out in Italy and
to the Zurich University of the Arts
especially to you Philip Tron
I can't even say everything I want to
thank you for I would not be standing
here without the love and support of my
family - and my close friends especially
I want to thank my mom because you are
always supporting and loving me no
matter what I do and my dad because you
always remind me to make use of my
imagination because it is the greatest
gift
we made this film that is a story about
someone who no longer functions in our
society the way he is supposed to and
about how we should find a way to treat
and respect those people it is a story
about caring for each other and feeling
responsible for two more week and that's
why my deepest gratitude goes out to the
Academy and its members for honoring our
film with the student Academy Award
finally my thanks goes to show on Hector
and their team and to all the film
makers I've met in this past and very
inspiring week and I'm proud to be in
this competition with such talented
filmmakers so congratulations through
all of you and good night